(audience applauding)
- All right!
- Oh my God, so, have y'all ever met?
Y'all met before?
- We have not met before.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- But I'm gonna talk about, you know,
you love "Percy Jackson," right?
- I love, yeah.
- Yes.
I love "Percy Jackson" too.
- I know.
- And we'll talk about it
later on, but we'll get there.
- And now you have kiddos,
we were talking about it in the break.
- Yes.
- You have kiddos,
so, you get to like
revisit again with them.
- I do, I do-
- That's fun.
- And I love reading to my kids.
- Me too.
- Yeah, my two boys are
nine and 11 right now.
- Yeah.
- And I still
will read to them, and we just finished up
the "Percy Jackson" series.
- You did, the whole series?
- And we love the character
that you played, yeah, so.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Justin] It's awesome,
then watching the movies.
- I'm excited for the new series.
- [Justin] Yeah, yeah, we are too, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Wait, what?
- Yeah, Disney+.
- Disney+.
(audience laughs)
- Oh yeah, they're doing
a whole new series.
I'm not involved in it-
- Is it already out?
- But I'll promote it by-
- It's happening.
- It's already out right now?
- It's coming out.
- Coming out.
- Oh, okay,
I was like, where was I?
Oh, okay.
My kids are gonna freak!
- I think it's coming out soon.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Yes.
- Right on, right on, big shoes to fill.
So, wait, so, we're all about
starting out the new year
with like something we're
gonna do to, you know,
better for ourselves,
instead of setting a goal
that we'll probably fail at.
- Right, exactly,
yeah, hello, welcome, yeah.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Yeah, no, for me, I
mean, it's just like,
the self-care routine
that I love is ice baths.
Now, I know, polarizing.
(audience laughs)
- No, I actually, I saw
a whole thing on this,
I've discussed this on the show.
- Yes.
- I saw a whole thing on this,
it's really good for you.
- Yeah, yeah, well,
like, it became popular-
- How long can you take it?
- I've been in it for
like five, seven minutes,
but then I love getting out,
and getting into the sauna after that.
- Have you ever done an ice bath?
- Yeah, we actually just bought one.
- You did?
- Yes, yes,
it's so great!
- Have you done it yet?
- Yes.
- That doesn't sound fun, yeah.
- Yeah, no, but-
- But it is really
good for you, apparently.
- Yeah, it is.
- Yeah.
- [Justin] I enjoy it.
- Okay, well, I'll just
take y'all's word for it
for the time being.
What are your most fond
memories of "Idol?"
'Cause people always ask
me about "American Idol,"
and sometimes I'm like,
sometimes I don't remember.
Like, if you think 20
years back in your career,
and you go, huh?
- [Justin] Yeah.
- Like, some of it's hard.
- Well, it's wild because
we got shot out of a cannon,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I love just being
around, and the fact that
we were at the beginning of things, so-
- And we didn't know.
- Nobody knew what was up,
yeah.
- Yeah.
- The stakes weren't super high for us.
- That was pretty cool, actually.
- Yes, it was.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then we got to hang out so much,
and I can tell you this,
if you ever have the chance
to see Kelly, and she ever says, "Hey,
do you wanna play a card game?"
Don't.
(audience laughing)
- I'm always been competitive.
- She's a killer.
It was "Speed"-
- And too much "Speed"-
- Do you remember "Speed?"
- Yeah,
I was gonna say "Speed," yeah.
- Yes!
We would hang out and
we would play "Speed,"
because there were these
huge swaths of times,
and like, we would play "Speed-"
- I love "Speed."
- And I think I may have won twice
in the hundred times
that we played together.
- I love "Speed."
- [Justin] Yeah, obviously.
- I know, but I feel like I
have natural caffeine going in,
(audience laughing)
you know,
I've always been like, brr!
- Yeah, yeah!
- Like, you know?
So, it was really my game.
- It was ridiculous.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, and I just, I was like,
I just kept coming back for more.
- Okay, so after "Idol," I love this,
you went on to mentor younger talent.
(Just mmhmms)
That's really cool, I love,
I do that in a sense on "The Voice," like.
(audience applauding)
- Yes, absolutely, yeah.
- I love doing that
'cause we were so blessed,
like, with that experience,
and it's kinda cool
to be able to give that back to someone.
- Right, well, I mean, you go
back to my childhood, right?
And I'll never forget, it was 1986,
I was in Atlanta, Fulton County Stadium.
The Jackson Five were on the stage.
Michael came back to be
with his brothers, right?
- Your childhood was so
different from mine, but yes.
- Right, it was very
different, we know this.
- (mmhmms) Yep, yep.
- And so, I remember
looking up at the stage,
and seeing the lights, and
the smoke, and the costumes,
and they're doing like
the, all the choreography,
and everything,
- Yeah.
- And for no apparent reason,
I pointed up to the stage,
said to myself, I wanna do that.
I was eight years old,
and then, oh so many years later.
- Yeah.
- You, me,
and our friends were on a stage in front
of 30,000 screaming fans
night after night, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- And I realized that I
had fulfilled that promise
that that eight year
old had made to himself.
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- [Justin] And that-
- And not many people
get to do that, yeah.
- Right, and not many
people get to do that,
but my hope is is that
someone looked at us up there,
or someone looks at you here, and this,
and says, you know what?
I wanna do that.
- But you inspire someone
like that.
- Right,
that you inspire someone.
- Yeah.
- And so, to be able to then go back,
and help people avoid the
pitfalls that I fell into.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And make it a little bit, I mean,
they're gonna have
their own ups and downs.
But to make it easier for me feels like,
okay, that's my legacy.
'Cause I know at some point,
they're not gonna remember
anything that I did
on a long enough timeline, right?
- Yeah.
- But the fact that
you can just touch someone's life,
and make it a little bit easier, and make,
let them follow their
passion, huge for me.
- I think that's really important
for everybody doing the industry,
even you've been doing this for so long,
to look at younger actors too, and go,
"Hey, just so you know,
like, you're killing it,"
or you're like supporting
them, or telling them, like,
"Hey, this didn't work for
me, it might work for you,"
but just letting you know.
- Yeah.
- I think that's always
important to look behind you.
- Yeah, of course, to reach back, because-
- Yeah.
- You just help people,
you know, in such a fast paced world,
to be able to grow, and to
adjust quickly is important.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And so, if you can help someone and-
- It's a beautiful thing to
help someone, it feels good.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- It makes all this kinda
make more sense, doesn't it?
- Yeah.
I gotta say, my kids are
gonna love this show.
So, you're, now, you're the
voice of a new animated show.
So, tell us about "SuperKitties,"
are you the villain?
- I am.
- I love that you get to be the villain!
- Yes, yes, I know, me too.
- That's the,
you get the best songs.
(audience applauding)
- I know! (laughs)
- You get like the more
fun like character, yeah.
- (laughs) Yeah, it's totally great.
So, it's "SuperKitties,"
and it's set in the town of Kittydale,
and these kitties are just regular kitties
until they get the SuperKitty call
from their animal friends.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then usually the reason why they get
the SuperKitty call, and they change
into their SuperKitty outfits
is because a villain like me-
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Comes and does something,
so, I play Cat Burglar,
of course.
- That's a great name.
- And yeah, exactly.
And who likes to steal
all the right things
for the wrong reasons.
But the cool thing about the show is,
and the cool thing about Cat Burglar
is that he always learns his lesson,
and he always apologizes.
So, it's about friendship,
problem solving, camaraderie,
and I think it's-
- Is it full of music?
- It's a really fun show.
- Like there's-
- Yes!
- Okay, 'cause I love that.
- Yes, I love to sing in it too.
Yeah, that clip you showed-
- Yeah.
- Is one of the parts where
I get to sing too, so.
- I love doing animated stuff.
Have you done animated stuff?
- Little bit.
- Okay, I love it.
It's so fun.
- IT's so fun.
- You go, you come in your PJs-
- In your sweats, yes!
- Yes!
- That's my favorite thing to do.
- And you get to like, pretend,
and play like you're a kid,
and your voice can be
different, it's just like fun.
- That's it, play.
- Yeah.
- That's my most favorite
part, and you know,
it's like, when you're
doing like live theater
like I've been fortunate to be able to do,
it's like once the show starts, that's it.
You know, it's great,
and there's something
beautiful about that,
but there's also something-
- That energy.
- About like, the ability
to be on set, and like
have take after take, and just to play,
and to see what happens.
And that's something I love to tell
the people I work with,
it's like, "Hey, wait,
you know this thing
you're stressed out about?
It's supposed to be fun."
- Yeah, oh my God.
- Like,
you're supposed to play.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, this is, we get paid to play.
- Yeah, no, I always
tell the other artists
I work with on "The Voice" too that too.
I'm like, "Have fun.
I mean, I know it's
like a lot of pressure."
- [Justin] Right, right!
- "I've literally been in your
shoes, but like, have fun,
like, remember this is
a really cool moment."
- [Justin] Yeah.
- But I think that all of us, like,
anytime we've had any success,
that's like really important to do,
to look back, and like help other people
get to where you've
been, and where you are.
- Yeah.
- So, that is so cool.
I love seeing you, oh my gosh.
- I love seeing you.